this is a production of Cornell
University
Thank You Don I'm Marcia M Shively for
those of you who don't know me and I'm
the faculty advisor for a cordis forum
so what a pleasure to be here today to
be introducing students will be telling
you about some new directions for Hortis
forum I do just want to have a couple of
shout outs we've moved moved to a shared
leadership approach with this really
vibrant undergraduate club and I just
want to acknowledge Lea cook who serves
as an international trip advisor for
these students and and Betsy lamb who's
recently joined our team she is someone
who has a real passion for working with
students doesn't always get that
opportunity and really enjoys for
example the shorter trips here that
students engage in and has been serving
more recently as she's entering in as
something of a meeting advisor and Neil
Matson gives them guidance on growing so
I just feel as if it's important to name
the ways in which where does forum as an
undergraduate club is really drawing on
a lot of our resources very wisely I
think you guys can work that out so what
a pleasure to introduce Sarah and Hawke
today over the past couple of years
where does forum has been going through
some really exciting changes and these
two have been at the heart of some of
those changes really strengthening
accountability and responsibility in the
club and the team of officers officers
do receive credit for Hortis forum
officer leadership development and there
are a handful that aren't here today
just because of their schedules but
Sarah and Hawke will be guiding you
through some changes that they've been
experiencing Sarah was the primary
Hortis forum treasurer for the previous
two consecutive years and I have to tell
you accountability has been her thing
just really strengthening that whole
piece in terms of working with sips at
admin
just really strengthening the
accountability for the Treasury she's a
senior and plant sciences and
agricultural sciences with a
concentration in crop production and
management she's also an undergraduate
researcher in Kettering's lab working on
her senior honors thesis and soil
nutrient management and she's looking to
pursue a graduate degree in soil
sciences upon graduation in May hock
Bois is the current predator president
of Fortis forum and the previous sales
treasurer from last year and he's a
senior in Ag Sciences with focuses in
horticulture Plant Sciences and
education
he's from Sullivan County New York and
was raised on a maple syrup farm with
diversified agriculture and after
college he's looking into the
horticulture industry public
horticulture and education having drawn
positive experiences from working with
both the Cornell Botanic Gardens youth
education program and ball horticultural
trial and show Gardens and I'm sure
after you hear them today you'll see
that they should likely have no trouble
going forward in the world given their
the way in which they're ready to
embrace innovation and change so what a
pleasure to introduce them today thank
you for giving them your attention all
yours Thank You Marcia for that
introduction good afternoon everybody
once again my name is hawk and this is
sarah and we are representing the Hortis
forum Cornell's undergraduate
horticulture Club today the reason for
our presentation is because last spring
we applied for an engaged leadership
opportunity grant through engaged
Cornell and one of our pay ups to that
was to have a presentation at the end of
the year kind of summing up our
reflection on the whole grant process
just a little background on for this
forum we have a mission statement that's
cultivating a positive social community
which fosters a passion for plants and
teaches the value of horticulture we try
to embody this and all the activities
that we do and it's a plethora of
activities throughout the semester
Wednesdays we usually have meetings
every week except for the first
Wednesday which is an officer meeting
that's where we do hands-on activities
industry tours whether they're local or
even on campus and then we do Club
updates so general club happenings
you've probably seen sales around campus
before we do Friday sales it's either a
man Lobby physical sciences building or
sometimes Hope Plaza and then we do
social events also so where we kind of
connect to the community but also have
our name tied to it as well so more on
our engaged leadership grant we have a
three-part program that Sarah is going
to outline for us today so when we were
looking back at our grant we kind of
split it up into three main problems or
topic areas that we were kind of
experiencing so the first is
horticultural learning opportunities we
realized we were kind of falling into a
routine and we wanted to make sure we
are getting the most out of this
learning experience
the second is exploring public and
purposeful mission again we have this
beautiful mission statement but we
weren't utilizing it and we weren't
necessarily following it to its most
capacity and the third part is a
leadership model alteration so we
realized that the way our leadership
model was set up we weren't really
utilizing each other and the work wasn't
being distributed accordingly so the way
we're gonna kind of explain this grant
and our processes is that we're gonna
start by telling you about what problems
we were facing and then how we addressed
it through the grant followed by the
outcomes what is going well what are we
still working on yep I'll start with the
first part which is the new hoard of
cultural opportunities and we looked at
this through the lens of plant sales so
one of the big things that artists forum
does is we have to greenhouse base up at
kpl greenhouses where we produce a whole
bunch of different plants some of the
problems that we have with producing
these plants is that we're selling to a
flooded market we usually have people
who are buying the same plants over and
over again and when we're only doing
sales at three different locations we
see the same people you can only make so
much money out of man lobby we also have
a lack of learning opportunity with the
same plants we have a whole bunch of
begonias and a whole bunch of snake
plants usually we just divide them or
leaf cuttings from them and we do the
same thing over and over again so it's
gets very monotonous and we're not
really expanding our learning
opportunities that way and we're not
really paying attention to what our
consumers need if we're operating as
like a club business for fundraising we
should also know what we're selling to
who we're selling and why we're selling
so our steps towards improvement through
the grant we decided to consolidate and
transition one of the two of our
greenhouse bays into a spring vegetable
starter this met this method had us take
our separate succulent house and
tropical house combine them into one and
make sure there are practices were on
point so they're all combined
sterilizing this newly opened house and
then replacing it with seeded vegetables
so seeds is a new opportunity that we
started to step in rather than a leaf
cutting or division propagation through
this we had an opportunity to learn
about the growing of vegetable crops
bedding plants and then hanging basket
through a donation with dr. bill Miller
and finally we actually could expand our
market to the Greater Ithaca community
and not just students these are some of
the varieties all these pictures that
you see were taken by cordis forum
members in our greenhouses or later on
we'll see some pictures from Steve
riders now we're talking about outcomes
so positive outcomes of doing this
change in the sale perspective is that
we learned how to grow a wider variety
of plants in the greenhouse it expanded
our market so bedding plants and
vegetables you're not really going to be
selling to students here we're here for
only a semester we geared more towards
the Ithaca community we had to send out
publications and to staff so they could
have gardens over the summer we increase
our membership product participation
with many projects by sending out email
saying this is a new opportunity that
you can get involved in it's hands-on
and it's gonna take a lot of work we
hope to see you there and then finally
we had a connection to the community we
weren't just selling a house plant we
were selling something that they could
use for food and it had a very good
impact on our club some of learning
opportunities we didn't really want to
say negatives throughout this
presentation this is just something that
we can work towards in the future the
sale timing and planning we sowed our
seeds
too early and we ended up having
tomatoes that were almost four feet high
trying to put individual labels in each
four inch pot was extremely difficult we
started to have some leaning plants tip
over entire flats flip onto the floor
and have to throw those out our sale
time actually conflicted with the Ithaca
garden sale downtown so we're trying to
pull the same type of consumers from
Ithaca who's been going there for years
up to our greenhouses at kpo which is
still kind of hard to describe how to
get to we also didn't budget and how
much plants to produce and kind of match
it to the consumers need for that so in
coming next year's we're gonna have to
definitely evaluate how much we had
leftover and how much we should actually
sell for the next year
and I talked about our growing issues we
also had a really warm greenhouse and
the tomatoes liked that so I kind of
just perpetuated our problem we did not
use any sprays when we were growing
these plants we used a lot of beneficial
insects and when we have a lot of leaf
cover and dense planting it just
increases pest potential moving forward
so our next steps we will be doing a
spring sale next spring we're going to
tweak how what varieties we use and how
much we're going to grow we're also
going to seed them at the right time
hopefully we use Neal Matson and we're
going to use them again as a resource
and hopefully have a better outcome for
that and then we're gonna look for a new
sale opportunity position kpo
greenhouses as I mentioned it was hard
to get to livestock position pavilion
has an actual address that we can send
to consumers to say come here to the
livestock pavilion will have plants for
you so the next part of our grant really
focuses on exploring public and
purposeful mission so while we have this
club and we we love plants and we want
to share that love with others we were
so kind of struggling to find good
meaning and to have that meaning match
our actions so the existing problems
again are just embodying our mission of
cultivating a positive social community
which fosters a passion for plants and
teaches the value of horticulture we
were often finding that we were profit
driven but we wanted to be philanthropic
so it was kind of finding a good balance
and also motivating our members
you see the same vision so through the
grant we wanted to work with Geneva
community gardens to grow Transplant
special transplants for that program we
also reached out to cows departments to
find expert experts in different fields
and to make sure that we were building
our knowledge and our skill sets
accordingly
we reached out to Professor Perrault CEO
to talk about marketing and how we want
others to see our club and what we want
our club brand to be just as one example
we also hosted a cow's wide workshop on
community gardens with Fiona dougherty
dr. Steve riders and dr. Christine smart
who are able to talk to us as well as
cows members and other students and
faculty and staff about how important
community gardens are and what
opportunities we have there so things
that were really positive on Cynthia and
I you can see us there on the right we
went to the giveaway day in May and it
was really excellent
it was so humbling and and great to see
community members really excited about
these plants and asking great questions
about how to grow them and how to care
for them and looking at producing their
own vegetables the plants were
distributed to a dozen community gardens
around Geneva and of 5,000 pounds of
fresh produce that was produced
throughout Geneva approximately half was
thrown from Hortis foreign plants so you
know for a first-year program that's
really exciting to know that our efforts
here in Cornell can make a big impact
elsewhere some challenges we faced was
that our giveaway day was the same day
as our budding plant sale so we were
kind of struggling to find the students
to go to the giveaway day and it was
hard to recruit student participants
overall about volunteering I think
people liked the idea but during final
exam period and throughout school
everyone's busy and everyone's stressed
and then sometimes difficult to find
ways to motivate people to follow
through and just getting people there to
see how exciting and how worthwhile
project is moving forward we would love
to do another giveaway day maybe even
having more giveaway days and sending
different students on different days to
different locations so that way we can
increase our impact and also get more
Club members excited about this project
we're also looking for opportunities for
Community Impact looking at different
community gardens looking at different
places where we can distribute our
plants or looking for different niches
where we can grow different plants which
also ties back into our learning
potentials now on to the most
complicated part of our grant writing so
we actually got a specific type of
engaged Cornell grant it was under the
leadership branch of it
the original leadership model that we
have is one way our new proposed kind of
hybrid variety of leadership model is
another way I'll try to explain it the
best that I can if you have any
questions during this point feel free to
raise your hand so the problems that we
had with our existing model of
leadership is that we have a vertical
hierarchical leadership model where we
had a president a vice president
secretary and so on it was an uneven
distribution of work so some officers
really wouldn't be there unless it was
super needed for them to be there and
others would be there 100% of the time
and it was an unclear and overlapping
job descriptions for example one of the
things that we had is who's going to
post on social media is that the
Secretary's job is at the webmasters job
and finally we have a club of officers
it's a core group of students who we
find always at the green house or always
at our sales but we have a listserv
that's over a hundred members log so we
try to evaluate like how are we going to
include the other steps towards
improvement we developed a horizontal
leadership model instead of a vertical
model we created a whole new sales
position that would cater towards that
specific positions needs and then we
added consulting advisors like Marsh
mentioned in the introduction we added
leah dr. Madsen and dr. lamb so now a
visual so you can see what the original
hierarchical leadership model looked
like we have four greenhouse workers
usually two of them
head greenhouse managers and then two of
them are apprentices usually we hope
that the apprentices would take on the
greenhouse manager position in the next
year however that's not always true one
of the main problems that we find with
this is that there's no clear connection
with who's interacting with our members
so we have all these physicians but no
real direction and where to go to with
our horizontal leadership model we try
to change that we created work teams
instead of just positioned so that we
have a direct connection to our members
you can see now that we have the sales
treasurer position on the far right but
we also have the greenhouse webmaster
public relations treasurer and under
that whole umbrella is the president
position who's more acting like a CEO
asking to make sure that all the working
groups are doing what needs to get done
and that they're actually saying on top
of their tasks at any point in my
position as the president I can step in
and help another group out but it's not
really my main responsibility as much as
the team and the members positives that
we've had for this is that we've had an
improvement in the tasks distribution we
have now clear expectations on what
working team is supposed to do what
we've strengthened our knowledge base
through faculty connections we can draw
on different specialties that we have so
dr. Mattson has all of this greenhouse
production knowledge I'm sure we're
going to be calling on dr. lamb for IPM
and the greenhouse for the spring and
then we have more member inclusiveness
fostered through these explicit
connection with working groups we're now
sending out signups and say if you want
to work with Maya
our sales treasurer who's doing
marketing and sales organization sign up
and connect with her so that's gonna
come up in like two slides it's moving
forward so if you hold on to that
thought I will get to it some of our
learning opportunities is the stroma
with involvement of the balance credit
volunteering and effort we have students
who were still seeing or just touch and
go when it comes to events if it says
free on it they're there if it says work
on it they're not
so we're trying to incorporate this
whole thing of like you can get
something if you put something in we're
trying to say that in a very nice way so
that we're not saying that this is
mandatory for you to be in this club and
then finally the accountability and
transparency that comes with these
officer positions we have five new five
exclaimed expanded positions but now all
of those positions need to work together
with each other to make sure that that
overlap is not going to happen again the
transparency is becoming because Marsha
is requiring us to do bi-weekly updates
which help everybody in the club I'm
just saying like what officer is doing
what for that coming week moving forward
we know that this is a workable model
it's not set in stone yet we just
transitioned into it it doesn't mean
that all of our problems are solved it's
going to be malleable for the future
outlook now the problem that we had that
Don just mentioned was that motivating
members to join these working teams how
are we supposed to do that if we're
having problems getting them to show up
to some of our meetings we're trying to
include a top-down enthusiasm so we have
working teams and I'm trying to
encourage them to reach out to members
be more than a net ID and have them show
your face at a meeting and show your
face at a sale to say hello my name is
hawk I'm the president would you like to
work with me on this project actually
getting your voice out there and making
that personal connection to the members
it's not happening 100% now it's still a
dream up in the air we're trying to pin
it down for next semester which is going
to happen in the reflection definitely
for this fall so just beyond the grant
we've been having a lot of success in
other areas of our club we've been more
excited about finding new ideas for club
meetings before we were kind of stuck in
these routines of doing the same
activities every year and with these new
changes has kind of sparked some
inspiration for new ideas we've been
really excited about doing more
community events such as the succulent
planter that was given to president
Pollock and Dean for which we had
students on the art squad helped to
plant such planter and it turned out
really great as you can see we want to
host more intentional free community
activities too
continue to get the community engaged
and to keep our members engaged as well
we're making new club partnerships and
reaching to the public and making sure
that we're not just falling into a
routine but we're really pushing
ourselves to be active in the community
and to be working with other groups to
make sure that we are getting the most
out of this experience so we'd like to
give a huge thank you to engaged Fornell
for sponsoring this grant and all of our
projects we also like to thank our
advisor Marsha game she's Lee who's been
with us every step of the way dr. Reiner
is doctor smart um Fiona Daugherty for
helping us with all the community garden
work as well as Kevin who is a he's now
a graduate student but he was an
undergraduate member and he's always
around and he takes great pictures and
he's really fun and was a great help for
this presentation we'd also like to
thank everyone else who's been there
with us throughout the way and everyone
who supports so one of the trade offs
horizontal management structures it's
harder to make decisions because people
evolve you've found that to be true and
have you done that yes so I have a very
strong opinion when it comes to making
decisions my philosophy is that if you
think of the idea you can also think of
a way to get it done so if someone for
example comes up with me that the idea
is saying oh it's a great idea to have
business cards I'm like that is a good
idea Maya is doing sales and you can
hand out business cards there how about
you collaborate with Maya and make that
happen so it's I'm very much so like
it's either a yes we can try to do it or
what are the problems with it how can we
work to fix it before we start rolling
with it but I usually hold the person
who comes up with the idea accountable
go ahead my question is what did the
engage Cornell grant provide you in
terms of resources and people that you
know could interact with or fight
mm-hmm so one of the problems that we've
had is the money struggle if we're
profit motivated sometimes we always
don't want to spend our own money to do
stuff especially when we have trips and
things going on engaged Cornell gave us
an opportunity to kind of take that
weight off our shoulders to do this
community deity donation they paid for
plant materials the growing time in the
greenhouses and then also some of the
outreach stuff so we did printing like
the plant varieties when we gave away
the plants instead like what they were
good for we actually only used a quarter
of the funding that we requested because
we got a lot of faculty donations to us
does that answer you a question okay you
mentioned that you're seeking new
collaborations and partnerships there's
quite a few students here who are part
of Soho has there been any efforts to
collaborate between artists and so um
actually from our experience there
hasn't been and that's definitely a
space and a void that needs to be filled
because we have a lot of the same goals
and we want to do the same things and
we're interested in the same topics but
absolutely that's definitely a space
that needs to be filled in the coming
months I think you guys had a sale or a
hands-on activity last semester we tried
yeah yeah some of the other partnerships
that we're looking into is the nature Rx
and Cornell mines matter a very strong
push these days are going to be that
plant in human wellbeing I have a
meeting on Wednesday with somebody from
nature rx that we're going to be working
with I just want to say that you know
we're thinking about this in the context
of horticulture and cows but if you
imagine the hundreds and hundreds of
clubs on campus the issues that they're
describing of a vertical leader
ship model and moving to a shared
leadership model is something that so
many clubs are struggling with on campus
so we actually have the eye of the
University in terms of watching the way
this is unfolding because it could serve
as a university model as well at you as
a model but I'm just really short on is
participation and national beauty it's
like a HSN guys have a chance to go
there double I and the opportunity there
for undergraduate Ball minutes I didn't
as you're going forward are you thinking
about maybe sort of expanding the vision
for what firm can do it maybe increase
participation and those sorts of things
and increase visibility for now Ashley
yeah so Hawaii this fall and we talked a
lot about that how our club doesn't
really seek professional then
opportunities per se and how it would be
so great to bring students to events
like that where we can make professional
connections and learn about the research
and horticulture that's going on across
the country so that's definitely an
opportunity maybe even through the next
big travel um
opportunity that comes up or I don't
know but that's definitely kind of a
direction that we've been thinking about
and talking about a lot yeah we do run
into the problem though is that we're a
widespread Club so we have students who
are not just in plant sciences we have
people who are engineers communication
majors and some even like all the way
down in Arts and Sciences for info side
when we try to just allocate our own
funding to that specific of an event it
kind of leaves out all of those other
people so it's kind of like even if
you're working sales you might not get a
majority of the funding towards what you
want to do because a SHS is very heavily
plans
research and it's maybe not so
applicable to an info science person or
a calm person in their direction SAF C
funding is going to become a good friend
to us hopefully next semester that's
going to help us with a lot more of the
local trips that we're going to do so if
we're going down to the Philadelphia
Flower Show SAF C funding can help with
some of the transportation kind of
lighten that cost load see you next year
speed is washing seats of Transportation
it is much easier to do Washington DC
and that's why we're adding dr. Lam
because we do have an ignorance about
stuff that's not going on around us was
supported by this engaged
Cornell grant cannot become sustainable
each year activity so in our grant we
actually wrote that we were having the
sale the same time as like the donation
so that that sale would perpetuate the
funding for the donation the next year
so even though we're gonna still
continue with some of the practices that
were under train a new leaf
we're not going to require any funding
next year for it because we had that
startup capital upfront to do all the
plants for the sale Marshalls
contributed so much in so many ways what
are your thoughts about how you can
ensure a continuation of this kind of
ESTJ forthright energy that you're
bringing to the you know really like
what can you do in the spring semester
to ensure that this positive strong
leadership continues I've definitely
looked into some new programs that are
like online to help with
kind of organization of the club itself
definitely going to start doing the
whole top-down enthusiasm push when we
have those working teams and we can
actually see those working teams
function it might be more of an emotive
ational aspect for our officers I'm
hoping that we can have a good
reflection at the end of the fall
semester I think our next meeting is the
end of this month
so we're gonna actually talk about what
we're going to do for the spring that's
kind of a little bit different from this
fall semester as I said it's still
evolving it's still gonna be malleable
as a personal thing for me I can stand
up here and say like we can do this we
can do this we can do this but just like
in any educational system if the people
who were supposed to implement it don't
enact it it's not going to catch at all
so that's one of the fears that we have
thought about while writing this grant
is we can do this for the duration of
the grant and said that we did it but is
it going to be sustainable after we
leave we do have the problem that we
have a lot of seniors as officers and
people who have been doing it for
continuous years all you heard that
sarah was an officer for two years
before she didn't do it this year I've
been in officers for two years I'm not
going to be here next year so we have
some people who are younger officers who
will take over hopefully next year and
we're trying to cultivate more people
who are either freshmen or sophomores to
join the club and kind of take that
leadership initiative in there hopefully
train them in the way that we want them
go ahead so first of all the two of you
coordinated the presentation really well
I was very impressed sitting here my
question is about public outreach to
save your current public outreach
involves science outreach to school
systems or is that among the list of
things you've considered okay well thank
you for the question um we are outreach
is trying to be a step forward we have
been invited into school programs before
trying to do just like a little bit talk
about how you grow plants however that's
never been a strong component just yet
it was one of the ideas was hey wouldn't
it be cool if that the outreach thing
is held strong by some of our members so
like myself and then the current
greenhouse grower
manager miles but it's something that
we're trying to look forward to if we
have connections from anybody in the
audience that would like to do some
outreach with us let us know and we'll
be able to partner with you any other
questions
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu